[Music]
you know one thing they don't know is
that you actually live in my
neighborhood in Los Angeles I
Koni moved into my neighborhood and I
always ask you for your address I ask
him for he always has an excuse not to
give me the the real address
it just never there's not been a right
time to like heaven oh well I I had an
orange soda recently and and I wanted to
share it with Conan and I didn't know
exactly where Coney was but I I that
didn't stop me so I went looking for him
and do you remember I've heard about
this well I think yeah they filmed it so
here here it is okay let's take a look
okay he's been here he's going in there
your secret safe how was it was it fine
with Conan oh you did it didn't you
you're wearing his weak
hi guys looking for Conan Cody you're
not Conan are you now we know what Max
Weinberg is doing I'm gonna fight oh
come on yes
Conan you're here have you seen coated
[Applause]
oh no way you look at the Conan O'Brien
you got any cool areas yeah I know where
he is
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thank you so much I'll see you soon
the cody boys hey how are you - fine the
cold man
[Applause]
that was you without makeup
[Applause]